Okay.
So today we're going to study our asymmetric information.
It's our last week and we're going to focus on signaling today.
And I'll spell it with one hour here as a concessions to the Americans.
All right,
so we're going to look,
we're going to dry this class,
the two parts.
And for the first part we're going to focus on the case where there is some very
flyable verifiable
information in the problem.
All right,
so we'll see what this means in a while.
But let me just set up an example and we'll see where that takes us.
So whatever turn to a game,
we know well by this stage,
which is the Corno game.
So there's two firms and they're competing in corners,
they're competing in quantities,
and we'll call the firms a and B.
And suppose that from B has costs,
so you'd be more formal.
These are constant marginal costs are equal to see m where m means middle or
medium or something,
and Fermi,
Fermi also has costs.
But those costs could come in one of three types.
It could be that from a has high costs and high costs are equal to middle costs
plus a little bit and it could be that from a also has medium costs and it could
be that from B from a has low costs and the low cost I just the medium costs
minus a little bit.
All right.
Now before this competition is going to take place before the actually going to
play the Cornell game from a has an opportunity for me is opportunity is to
reveal its costs to from sorry.
Yeah,
from a an opportunity to reveal its cost to firm B just to make them make this
more explicit initially from be obviously knows his own cost and sit there is
any one type from a obviously knows those cost as well as a firm a and firm B,
know what from bees costs are,
but initially,
although from a knows her own costs from B does not know from aes costs.
All right,
let's write that up.
So from B
knows only
it's costs
and from a
knows both costs.
Right.
The key decision we're going to focus on is that from a has an opportunity to
reveal its true costs to firm B.
Now I can do so in a verifiable way.
For example,
it could hire an accountant.
That accountant from a reputable outside firm could come in and,
and do the accounts for from a and then publish them in the Wall Street Journal
or something.
All right,
so for me,
I can do that.
And let's assume it's costless for it to do that.
All right,
so for me,
can costlessly
and verifiably
very fine verifiably reveal
it's costs
to be.
And the question is this gonna happen before they play core?
No.
The question is,
should from a reveal those costs or not,
right?
Should from a publicizing giveaway,
it's informational advantage.
If you'd like to firm B by telling from B what it's cost look like.
Alright,
so what do people think?
Let me just grab the mic and ask people a little bit.
Imagine you're the manager of from a,
from a,
are you gonna gonna tell B what your costs are or not wave a hand on their
shoulders.
Cold call here.
Let me cold call.
So,
so what's your name,
sir?
You,
you,
and,
and uh,
so I suppose you're the manager of firms.
Would you reveal the information or not?
Uh,
I would tell them only if my costs are lower.
All right.
So,
so you says I would,
I would reveal the information only if my costs were lower.
Now why,
why do you want to reveal the cost if you have lower costs?
Because they're,
my firms will produce out of lower costs,
so from B will,
um,
produce less because they know that we'll get most of the market.
Good.
So the point that it's used.
All right,
so the point that you is making is there may be some advantage in having the
other side?
No,
my costs,
if my costs are low,
since that may induce the other side to produce less,
let's just fill out that argument by putting in the corner diagrams or here's
the corner diagram.
Here's the quantity for from a,
here's the quantity for firm B.
Yeah.
And here is the best response or reaction curve for firm B.
All right.
And in this picture,
there's going to be three different possible reaction curves for from a,
each one corresponding to different costs.
So for example,
this could be the reaction curve or the best response for from a in the case in
which is medium.
All right?
But if it had lower costs,
what would happen to that reaction code?
But it's shift in,
would it tell,
tells what,
what happened to it.
So much I did out,
which shift out or I've had lower costs,
then it would shift out.
So this would be the best response for from a in the low case.
And conversely,
this would be the best response
for fun.
A in the high case.
All right,
so the point that,
uh,
that you as a is making on,
he should correct me if this is unfairly paraphrasing him,
is if I have low costs them,
I want the other side to know I have low costs because that puts us into,
uh,
into the,
into the equilibrium in which this is my best response curve.
And this is the other side's best response curve.
And from B ends up producing less.
And I end up lowering,
lowering its production.
Is that right?
So the key idea here is that this is a game and we've had often,
this is a game of strategic substitutes.
So if I have low costs,
I want the other side to know that I have low costs because it will cut back its
production,
which helps me.
All right?
On the other hand,
if I have high costs,
then I kind of liked to remain hidden.
I don't,
I really don't want the other side to know that I have high costs.
All right?
Because I have a high costs than the other phone is actually going to increase
their production.
And that's gonna hurt me.
All right.
But notice I've twisted the question a little bit.
The question I actually asked you was would you reveal the information about
your costs?
And I flipped that around to a slightly easier question,
which is,
what would I like the other side to know?
All right.
Now what would it like the other side to know?
I'd like the other side to know if I have low costs,
I'd like the other side note to know if I have high cost,
but that's not quite the question we asked.
The question we asked was would you given whatever your cost star reveal that
information to the other side.
And I think what you is told us is to take that what he said.
If you said if I had low costs,
I'm going to reveal it to the other side.
Is that right now?
All right,
so so far,
what do we know so far?
We know
that if I have low costs
then I will reveal it.
All right,
so you probably know that.
But what if I don't have low costs?
What if I have middling costs or high costs?
Wow.
Let's take these in turn.
What about height?
What about middling costs?
What should I do if I have middle,
middle level costs?
All right,
so somebody sort of hand that was,
let me go and take advantage of that and hang on,
I'll come back.
What's your name?
Shout out
Alec.
Um,
shout it out to people.
The hair.
Alec,
go ahead.
I think he should still review because they know if you had low costs you would
reveal and so if you had a middle costs and you didn't reveal,
then they could think that you either had middle costs or high costs and it's
better for you to just reveal that you had middle costs.
Good.
So good.
Never had to people here that,
let me just repeat that.
All right,
so you might think you might think if I have middle costs,
you might think that I could reveal or not reveal depending on what the other
side thought.
However,
what onyx arguing correctly is if I don't reveal that I have middle costs,
the other side from B knows that my costs are not low.
The only way they could mistake me if they could think I'm a high cost farm,
they know him.
No low cost from how do they know I'm going to low cost phone because the low
cost firm would have revealed that was used arguments.
All right,
so let's see.
This low cost firms are revealing.
If I'm a middle cost from,
if I don't reveal no one's really any doubt,
I'm not a low cost form,
so all I could be is a middle cost from or a high cost from all I can have is
this reaction curve,
which is the one I actually have or this reaction curve.
So if I don't reveal,
then the other side might think that I have high,
I have high costs,
in which case they're actually going to increase their production and hurting
me.
Hang on a second.
All right,
so since since the low cost from is going to reveal the medium cost wants to
reveal to ensure that no one thinks it's high cost.
All right,
so that's a low cost reveals and therefore
therefore see and reveals as well
to prevent,
prevent being
mistaken
for a high cost from now.
There was a question,
let me come down and collect the question.
Yeah,
you're just going to ask,
but if you have ever reveal cir both for the lower and middle cost,
then they're obviously going to know and he's a high cost,
which means that the concealing doesn't do any good.
Exactly,
exactly.
And your name is Bethany.
So Bertha is pointing out that once we know the low cost types gonna reveal,
we know that the middle cost type is also going to reveal so as not to get
mistaken for being high cost,
which means if you're running a high cost from,
it really doesn't matter whether you reveal or not because you're going to be
revealed by the fact that you didn't really feel that,
right?
Right?
How'd you been low cost?
You would have revealed had you been middle cost,
you would have revealed and therefore whether you choose to reveal or not,
everyone knows that you are high cost.
So therefore,
okay,
therefore
c h is revealed is revealed.
Everyone see that?
All right.
Okay.
Now notice that this argument we've just constructed,
there were three types of fun,
high,
middle,
low.
But I constructed exactly the same argument,
albeit somewhat more tediously with a hundred for a hundred types of firms,
right?
Firms that had absolutely the lowest cost firms that had the 99th,
uh,
you know,
the 19th highest cost,
98 foot,
highest costs,
97 past cost.
And so on.
And this argument would have been exactly the same at each stage.
The from that left in the analysis who has the lowest cost,
we'll want to reveal to distinguish itself from those who haven't revealed quote
yet unquote.
Right.
And therefore we'll get unraveling and we'll,
we'll,
we'll get information to be revealed and notice,
interestingly,
we'll get information to be revealed beyond the median,
right?
So the 50 the 51st highest costs from or reveal,
therefore the 50th highest cost farmer of yield there for the 49th and so on.
In fact,
the only firm who owed explicitly,
actively reveal themselves is the firm who has absolutely the highest cost.
And as Bethany points out there going to be revealed anyway.
All right.
All right,
so this is an idea.
This idea is called informational
unraveling
and again,
and keeping for my American audience,
I'm going to put one hour in unraveling.
Is that right?
There's one Ellen in America,
right?
So much of just check that on Google or something.
I think that's correct.
All right.
What's the lesson here?
So one lesson is that this happens.
We'll come back to that,
but another lesson,
perhaps the more important lesson is often the lack of information,
the lack of somebody signaling to you,
the lack of somebody trying to tell you something,
conveys information by,
this was the point that Bethany was making.
The fact that the high cost from doesn't in fact go out from reveal information
to you reveal something about what it knows.
All right,
so use initial comment was correct.
If I was the high cost from,
I'd like to remain hidden,
but I can't remain hidden from your point of view as the receiver of the
information.
There's information in the lack of the attempt to convey information,
lessen
the lack of a signal,
the lack of it,
Tim,
to affirmed a signal you some information.
The lack of a signal
can be informative.
So this is an often forgotten lesson.
It's a very simple idea,
but there's a natural tendency when you're dealing with information to focus on
the evidence that is that rather than the evidence.
That's not that.
All right.
There's an expression that goes with this.
Ah,
the expression is silence speaks volumes,
right?
Who heard that expression?
Silence speaks volumes.
All right,
let me give you one other example.
so there's a,
there's a Sherlock Holmes story,
by the way,
do you all know who Sherlock Holmes is?
Yeah.
Good.
Okay.
So there's a Sherlock Holmes story in which Sherlock Holmes solves the murder.
He figures out who did the murder and Dr. Watson,
who's his sidekick,
is trying to figure out how homes that possibly have solved the murder.
And he says,
how did you solve the murder?
And Holmes says it's because of the,
it's because of the barking dog.
All right?
And,
and Watson says,
what do you mean it's cause the barking dog,
the dog didn't bark.
Ryan Holmes says,
that's exactly the point.
The fact that the dog didn't bark didn't make any sound tells us who must have
committed the murder.
Right?
It's very easy to fall into the trap of being Watson and to ignore the thing
that didn't happen and focus on the things that did happen.
So here,
it's easy to forget that actually the high cost from is revealed by doing
nothing.
All right,
so this is the idea.
Okay.
The silence can speak volumes.
Every year I go back and try and figure out what that quotation is from and I
can never find it.
Anybody who finds it,
I will,
I will give them a prize of some sort.
I originally,
I thought it must be Shakespeare,
but it doesn't appear to be.
All right.
So this is a little,
little example involving core.
No,
but I want to try and convince you,
I'm gonna say no.
I'm trying to convince you that this example is more generalists,
but let's pick up the question.
Yeah,
sorry.
Go ahead.
Isn't it possible that there's an equilibrium where it's,
uh,
the,
the cost of remaining hidden as a middle cost,
uh,
from outweighs the benefit,
I mean,
outweighs not,
not,
not if we take the model,
literally not.
Do we take the model and corner?
Literally.
Because if you,
if,
uh,
suppose supposedly from B doesn't know whether you're high or middle,
then he's gonna he's with your cost is somewhere in between,
right?
And that,
and relative to your cost being middle,
he's going to produce more.
That's the point here.
Now it's true in a richer model than maybe some other advantage and having
information hidden,
but that would have already applied to the local.
Let me give you some other examples and we'll see.
We'll see this in other contexts and see that it might actually ring true.
All right?
So one other example,
uh,
involves uh,
a resumes.
All right?
So this example requires some explanation for the Non Americans.
How many of you are non Americans here?
All right?
So one thing you need to know as non Americans is the way in which people write
resumes in America and don't want to resume is write a CV or resume,
right?
So when you look at a typical resume from an American student,
if you are not American,
for those of you who aren't American,
um,
how should I put this politely?
Um,
it has a tendency to make you want to vomit.
Is that that does that.
Yeah.
Okay.
So that's basically the polite version of what I was going to say about that.
Uh,
all right,
so,
so why does it have a tendency to make you want to vomit?
Because Americans have a tendency to put down everything on their resumes.
So if they were,
if they were a captain of the chess team in third grade and they are now they're
40 and applying for a job,
it still says I was captain of the chess team in third grade.
And this is particularly true when it comes to public service when it comes to
sort of moral acts.
All right?
So most people in Europe will be a bit embarrassed about writing their good
deeds on their resumes.
But Americans,
there's a little spot on their resume,
which is about their good deeds are their public service and they put everything
into one.
I was eight,
I helped a little lady,
little old lady across the road with her shopping basket.
And there it is on their resume,
right?
Right.
Now.
So why?
Why is it that Americans reveal so much information on their resume?
All right,
well,
think about informational unraveling,
right?
So my resumes,
a verifiable information is a,
it's a,
it's hugely costly to be caught cheating about what would your resume.
So basically you're not going to lie on her resume.
All right?
And imagine if I'm a admitting students that say to law school,
to Yale Law School,
and I'm reading the student's resume out in the spot where I'm expecting to see
public service.
There's nothing written there,
all right?
What do I assume about that student?
What do I say about that student?
I assume that the person didn't nothing,
right?
This person has been a self serving evil,
get their entire life right?
It has never even helped a little old lady across the road.
All right?
So people put down everything,
even these minimal things,
even these pretty,
um,
shockingly tiny acts of charity to reveal themselves from those people who did
absolutely nothing that are basically the devil incarnate.
All right?
All right.
All right,
so this is about resumes.
Let's just take this a bit further.
How many of you from Los Angeles?
All right.
So in Los Angeles,
I'm,
I'm led to,
but I'm told,
you know,
you can confirm this or not.
There are lots and lots of restaurants and this is true,
right?
Lots of restaurants and some of these restaurants are good and some of them are
bad.
And more to the point for today's Today's example,
some of these restaurants are clean and some of them are not so clean.
Right?
This is true.
Yeah.
Okay.
So it turns out that until that late nineties,
the Los Angeles,
uh,
municipality rules,
local law said that every restaurant in Los Angeles County,
I think it was,
had to get visited by the health inspector and the health inspector would come
round,
I think it was annually and go to these restaurants and they would issue a
certificate.
And this was a health as advocates and originally on it in large letters,
let's I think of a red letters was either a or B or c,
right?
Maybe may even have been a minuses as well.
But for the purpose of the story,
let's just call it a,
B,
and C.
All right?
Now that was all the law said.
The law did not say that you had to display your health certificate anyway.
All right,
so what does this model tell us to expect about Los Angeles in the mid nineties
wow.
If you have,
if you're running a little restaurant in Los Angeles and you get an a health as
advocates from your restaurant,
from it,
from the health inspector,
what are you going to do with a certificate?
You're going to display it prominently in the window,
right?
A health certificate.
All right,
so if you're running a slightly less healthy restaurant,
maybe this is allies pizza chain again.
All right,
and you and you still get a B certificate from the Los Angeles Health Inspector.
Are you going to display it or not?
You're going to display it,
right?
Because?
Because why not?
We know the A's are going to display,
right?
The specific as we can get being given to everybody.
So you're going to display even obesity ticket.
Now I'm told from people who lived in Los Angeles at the time that you could go
round to the greasy spoon in Los Angeles and look through these grease smeared
windows with the cockroaches running up and down them.
And if you look carefully behind the cockroaches and the grease,
you'd see a certificate displayed that said,
see on it.
Right?
Right.
There was a d grade as well,
even the seas were displaying.
All right,
so that's pretty dramatic information unraveling.
Now I'm exaggerating slightly for to make it to make a separate point,
it turns out that it is in certain areas of Los Angeles,
you'd expect to see these health,
it gets displayed,
even the C's.
Right?
And in other areas you wouldn't expect to see the sea is displayed.
Which areas would you expect not to see people bothering?
Displaying best see your B minus certificates.
Any guesses?
The tourist areas,
right?
The tourist areas.
Because for this,
for this story about information on rallying to work,
the people who are the receivers of the information need to know that you got
the certificates.
Right.
So if you're a tourist was sanitize your,
no,
this is the systems in place and therefore,
you know,
if you're,
if you're a season ticket,
you're right next to Disneyland or something,
whatever it is,
right?
You can still pay,
you can still make some tourists sale without having tell guy you're about to
do.
So.
All right.
So that's a second example.
Let me give you a third example,
a little bit closer to home.
At the last curriculum reform at Yale,
there was a big debate about what to do with Credit d fail.
All right?
And one of the proposals for Credit d fail was to allow students to take
courses,
credit d fail.
But if they ended up getting an a or a B,
they could display the a or the B on the,
on their resume,
right?
So you can take,
they take your credit d fail,
but if they got a grade,
like an a or B or an a minus,
whatever,
then they have,
they can opt in and have it put it on their resume.
What's wrong with that?
This is a serious proposal that was made and I was on this committee right there
necessarily seriously made it right.
So I didn't make the proposal,
but this was made right.
What's wrong with this proposal?
Well,
what's wrong with a proposal?
What would,
what would,
what would displaying credit on your transcript come to mean?
It would come to me and see,
right?
It'll come to me and see because all the A's and the B's would an around ravel
information.
Alright,
so information can,
if information is verifiable and can be freely transmitted,
it has a way of coming out.
It has a way of coming out.
Let me give you one slightly more serious example.
As you will know,
if you're arrested in the US,
you should do this.
You have the right to remain silent and not saying you're all about to get
arrested,
but we'll usually be arrested.
You have the remote right terrain of silence,
right?
That Wright was true in Britain as well until recently when the government,
which isn't so big on civil liberties,
change the rules slightly.
So now you have the right to remain silence in Britain.
Signs in Britain barks,
the court has the right to take into account as evidence if you remain silent.
All right?
So what's that done to the right to remains?
I'll leave it to you to figure out where that's done to the right to remain
silent.
All right?
So this is,
this is an,
uh,
an area that does this,
this,
this idea that information unravels dependent on certain key parts.
And the most important part was that the information was verifiable.
Okay?
Like Monster,
that the information was verifiable and to get full unraveling all the way down,
in this case to the highest cost from you needed the people on the receiving
side of the information to actually know that that information was there.
So to get the full unraveling,
you really need something like common knowledge of the presidents of the
information.
All right?
But often the information that you have,
you have inflammation,
you want to reveal that information,
but unfortunately it's not so easily verifiable.
So we're going to focus on for the rest of the today is information that is not
verifiable,
right?
I,
let's start with an example that's pretty close to home.
A lot of you have been doing job interviews recently.
How many of you been going out either in interviews for internships or jobs in
the it?
And I know a lot of you missing class,
I'm assuming charitably,
that's what you were doing.
All right.
So,
uh,
when you go to these job interviews,
you could imagine that you're turning up for some job into unit.
Say it's boring.
Bank of Boston.
All right?
And you talking about this,
uh,
interview for Boring Bank of Boston.
And one of the things that Boring Bank of Boston wants to know is,
are you interested in working for Boring Bank of Boston?
All right,
that's a plus for that.
All right?
So what they tend to do is they ask you,
they ask you a,
more or less,
they say,
are you interested in working for Boring Bank?
All right.
Now,
by the way,
if you are asked the question,
Oh,
and you're interviewing for boring bank,
and you're asked the question by them,
are you interested in working for Boring Bank?
What answers should you give?
Here's the own said yes.
All right.
How much information is that in the fact you out?
So yes,
no at all.
Right?
Because clearly you want the option of,
of working for this bank is they're going to answer yes.
Anyway.
Now you may think this is just a fictional example.
It's not,
I talked to some recruiters from a bank in Boston that will refer to as Boring
Bank in Boston,
uh,
not so long ago.
And I asked them about hiring Yale undergraduate.
So what Yellen got to do to impress them.
And the recruiter who was a Yale graduate himself said to me that frankly,
Yale undergraduates do less well in these interviews then holiday it
undergraduates.
And I said,
no shattered and disappointed.
I said,
why?
And he said,
well,
when we asked them if they're interested in working for Boring Bank of Boston,
the Yale guys say things like,
well,
I know it sounds kind of boring.
All right.
Um,
the Harvard guys,
what do they do?
They show up with the Wall Street Journal folded over conveniently on the page
about Boring Bank of Boston.
And sometimes they're wearing,
you know,
a silly hat with,
I'm boring on it.
All right?
So I,
I tried to persuade this guy that despite this facts,
there's no,
there's really no information and the fact that the Harvard guys are telling
this,
and in fact you should hire the Yale people cause at least they were honest and
hey,
that might make the bank less boring in the future,
right?
This didn't work right?
So I need to persuade you guys to actually,
uh,
cough up and be dishonest here.
All right.
There's a lesson.
Here's a one lesson is if you are asked by an interviewer at one of these for a
summer internship or for a job later,
if you want to work for them,
the answer is yes.
All right?
It's one of the few questions with the answers.
Not backward induction.
It's just yes,
right?
The,
there's a secondary lesson here,
which is even interview,
if an Ngb off your for a bank is asking you in the interview if you'd like to
work for them,
you probably don't want to say yes,
but you probably want to work somewhere else,
right?
They're dumb enough to ask you that question.
You probably want to work for someone else.
All right?
But this isn't real.
This isn't a real problem.
The problem is here you are,
you have some information you'd like to convey.
Maybe you really are boring,
maybe really do want to work for this bank.
You want to convey this information,
but it's hard for you to persuade the employer I that is true because anybody
can say they want to work for the bank.
All right?
And more generally in life isn't the only about whether you want to work for a
particular bank or whatever happens to be.
It's also about whether you are a good worker.
Dot.
All alright,
so let's try and,
uh,
try and think about this in the context of not of workers being boring or not,
but at work as being good on us.
All right,
so we're going to look at a costly signaling marvel.
It's going to turn out,
this model is going to be about costly st signaling.
Add just for the purpose of the model,
we're going to assume that there are two kinds of workers in America that are
good workers will call him g
and that are bad workers,
and we'll call them B.
All right,
and what assume that the productivity of a good worker,
if you work for this further,
is going to be 50 or we gonna assume this is $50,000 whatever,
but that does forget units for now and just call it 50 and a bad worker.
Their productivity is only 30 all right?
So clearly all other things being equal,
the employer would rather employ a good worker or a bad worker and all other
things.
Being equal is important because then we have to pay the good work at more.
All right,
let's assume this is the u s economy.
So roughly 10% of the economy are good and 90% are bad.
Workers are like that.
All right?
These are the proportions in the U s all right?
And let's also assume that firms are competitive,
right?
So firms are flooding into the Yale careers office or the Yale careers fair,
and they'd just desperately trying to hire these workers.
There's competitive hiring going on.
All right?
So firms,
firms compete
for workers,
so
they're going to pay 50 to a worker.
They identify as good,
the pay 52 a worker.
They,
the firms identify as good,
am I going to pay 32 workers?
They identify as bad.
I want to hear you feel bothered by this being exact.
Think of it as 50 minus a penny and 13 minus a penny.
It's not gonna make any difference to the analysis.
All right?
So if they can't identify a worker,
then they can't identify a worker.
They think their work is just the average worker.
How much,
how much will the competitive wage,
what would the competitive wage of the average worker in this economy?
All right?
She's not,
it's not hard math question.
Everyone's scratching their head down here.
All right,
so this is,
this is,
uh,
what does it,
it's 50 times 10% and 30 times 90% which averages out as 32% all right?
So they'll pay,
they'll pay the average,
which is 32 to a worker.
They cannot identify.
All right?
Clearly in this model,
much like in the high cost firms we did,
we started with the good workers would like to be identified.
Is that right?
Because they get paid more and the bad workers do not want to be identified.
Right.
They'd roll.
They'd rather remain hidden.
All right.
The problem here,
however,
is the typically isn't a verifiable piece of information.
It's hard to verifiably communicate to the other side that you're a good worker.
So you guys are all good workers,
right?
You wouldn't be here otherwise.
We hope.
All right,
so you,
you show up to this firm,
this firm is looking for good workers and you could tell the firm,
I'm a good worker.
In fact,
I'm getting,
I'm betting most of you have tried doing that and your job interviews,
right?
I'm a good worker.
You could even do this in a costly manner,
right?
You could,
you could humiliate yourself by jumping up on the table and dancing on one leg
while singing some song about how you're a good worker.
All right?
Which will be human ea saying,
but it wouldn't in fact communicate to the firm that you're a good worker.
Why is it that your don't sing this beautiful Jig on the table of the interview
room singing this beautiful song about how you're a good worker?
Why doesn't that convince the firm that you're a good worker,
who's been in job interviews,
reason that anyone tried this?
How,
why is that not a can?
Why is that not a successful strategy?
Okay?
Yes sir.
Uh,
it's Steven is all right to shout out.
A bad worker could do that to my bag work.
You could do that too.
All right.
Check.
It's true that it's costly and humiliating to dance up on the table on one leg
and senior,
a good worker,
but it's noon.
More costly and humiliating for you than it is for a bad worker.
So if that worked,
a bad worker would do it too.
All right so many a song and dance isn't going to work.
All right.
Midea song and dance isn't gonna work.
It's gonna be hard to signal to the outside world that your a good workout.
All right?
That's going to be our starting point.
So we need a way for good workers to distinguish themselves from bad workers.
We need a way for them to signal.
And what's key about that sale is it has to be a signal that they can make and a
bad worker cannot make or alternatively a signal that they will want to make but
a bad worker will not want to make.
All right?
So don't sit on the table.
Doesn't do it.
And the reason it doesn't do it is bad workers and good workers.
It's a metric with respect to the dishonor of daunting on the table.
All right?
All right.
So we need a way for good workers,
you guys to distinguish yourself from bad workers.
Our skies.
All right?
All right.
How in the American economy,
what's the main way in the American economy in which good workers signal the
fact that they go,
that they managed to distinguish themselves?
What's the main signal used in the U s economy?
Somebody?
Yeah,
some education.
All right,
so the main signal,
the main signal in the u s not the only one by any means,
but the main signal,
he said education.
What's going to distinguish the good workers from the bad workers is the good
workers are going to have degrees,
more degrees,
better degrees,
whatever.
All right,
so what we're going to look at today is a model some of you have seen before,
but we'll do it in a bit more detail.
Perhaps a,
it's a mortal,
it's usual guy called Spence.
Mike Spence,
who actually won the Nobel Prize,
uh,
in large part for this model.
The reason we know he won the Nobel prize in large part for this model is he
didn't write practically anything else.
So it must've been for this moment.
All right?
So what we're gonna do is we're going to imagine that the degree,
the education that these people are going to get,
that's going to distinguish and show that they're good workers to the employers.
It's an,
it's assumed that the employees,
once again,
a banks,
whatever,
we're going to assume that the extra piece of education they're going to get is
an MBA.
Some of you out there are getting an MBA.
It was my Mbas areas.
That's my MBA student up that.
All right?
All right.
So the good workers are going to get
an Mba.
All right?
And the way this is gonna work,
the way it's gonna work,
it's gonna work on the cost of getting an Mba.
So it's got to get this to be a successful signal.
This signal difference from merely don't sit on the table.
It's either got to be the case that bad workers cannot get an Mba.
Orange got to be the case that it's so costly for bad workers to get an Mba that
they won't bother.
All right,
so we're going to make the difference in costs.
so we're going to suppose we're going to suppose that the cost,
the cost
per year.
Oh,
getting an MBA.
You're going of of a,
of being in business school.
So Mba education.
Okay.
Mba Education is
five five units.
If you're a good worker,
I am going to assume that the cost per year of going to som and getting an MBA
is a little bit over 10 so 10 and a penny.
Okay.
If you're a bad worker,
so nauseous.
I've assumed in this marvel that it's more costly per year to get an Mba at
Yale.
Say if you're a bad worker than a good worker.
Now what are those costs?
What are the costs of getting an Mba?
What's,
what's causing that cost difference?
Alright,
well let's be clear,
but it isn't,
it can't be the fees.
The fees are a large part of the cost of the feed.
And what are the fees are getting an Mba at Yale this yet way too much.
Right?
Right.
So the cost per year in terms of fees are enormous,
but the fees themselves are not going a good,
do a good job of distinguishing between good and bad workers.
Why?
Because they're the same for both parties,
right?
We want the,
we want them to,
which is differently costly.
So this is not,
this is not,
the fees can be the fees.
They're the same for both parties.
What other costs?
Other,
what are the costs?
Dollars to get to getting an education
is opportunity.
Cost,
right?
All of you are economists or half of you are going to economics majors.
So the first thing you should spring to mind is opportunity costs.
All right?
But actually opportunity costs.
Don't help me here,
munch,
because if anything,
you'd think that the opportunity costs of going and getting an Mba at Yale are
higher.
If you're a good worker,
then if you're a bad worker,
after all,
if you're a good worker,
you could stay home and not get an Mba form your farm,
your parent's garden.
Right?
And since you're such a good worker,
you'd have a high yield in carrots and whatever.
All right.
So wait,
where's the bad workers?
Not Gun,
but it is a thing,
right?
So this is not really about opportunity costs.
In fact,
we'll assume that there zero,
well assume there are no opportunity costs.
So what is it that's driving this cost difference between the good,
the good worker at SOM and the bad worker at Soi?
It's that somebody had that did,
was that an a a potential hostile there yet?
Yeah.
Is it that the present value of future wages for a good worker?
Ah,
okay.
So that,
so they were thinking about the future.
No,
let's just focus on the cost side.
Let's focus on the cost side.
You're right,
there's many different things going on in the future.
But I spoke on the cost side.
Uh,
had you before forced to have this guy,
um,
mental effort or mental effort,
right?
Mental efforts started was my MBA student up the areas.
Where is that up there?
All right.
It's pain and suffering.
Right?
Right.
Hey,
call Sam yet areas it's pain and suffering.
That right.
He's nodding good.
Right,
right.
It's having,
it's having that when you go to the NBA cost of thinking,
my God,
thank goodness I escaped being on the graduates and you go back to the NBA cost
and I'm there again.
Right.
I'm sitting the same horrible problem sets and you still can't read my
handwriting and you still have to deal with my accent.
Right.
Good workers find it easier to read my handwriting and deal my accidents.
All right.
So what it is,
it's,
it's the mental effort.
It's the pain and suffering.
It's the pain of the work.
Alright.
The only thing that distinguishes the costs of good workers from bad workers in
education is it so painful to do the work.
If we went to a party school,
right.
This wouldn't work.
Right?
It can wait.
That's where we can't just have potty schools.
We actually have to put you through some,
some pain in the classroom.
I'm looking for go get some confirmation from up there.
All right.
So the pain of the work is what distinguishes these things.
Okay.
Now I claim I claim that we could have an equilibrium in the society in which
there are good and bad workers in which good workers cost per year is less than
bad workers.
Cost per year of getting it in this case and Mba would do the same for Undergrad
education.
Let's focus on the MBA for now.
I claimed as an equilibrium in this society,
the could be an equilibrium in which,
uh,
getting an MBA takes three years prior.
So I claim
my claim
there is an equilibrium here,
an equilibrium
in which what happens in which there are three year degrees degree is
take
three years,
three year MBA sounds frightening.
Never mind.
All right.
In which the good workers
all get Mbas
and the bad workers
do not.
All right,
but to tell you this isn't equal number,
I'm going to do a little bit more.
So let me tell you one other thing.
So I cleaned as an equilibrium in which the degrees take three years.
All the good work has got Mbas.
All the bad workers do not get Mbas.
And what Andy Employees,
the employers identify Mbas as good workers.
Might just make this work.
It has to convince the employers to make it work I need and
the employers
identify and be a equals good and not MBA equals
all right,
so let's write.
Claim isn't equilibrium here and we don't want to do is I want us to show that
this actually isn't equilibrium.
All right?
Now that this is a slightly different kind of equilibrium to anything we've seen
in the class so far,
so I'm going to be a little bit slow and nerdy about what we need to check to
check that this indeed is an equilibrium.
All right,
Tony,
I'm going to leave some space on the board and you should leave some space to,
all right,
so my claim is this is an equilibrium and what we're doing guess and check.
I did the guests for you and we'll do the checks together to check.
I claim I need to check two things,
two things.
All right?
One,
I need to check
that.
No type.
We'll deviate
for me,
my type,
I mean types of worker.
Neither the good types of workers will want to deviate,
nor the bad types of worker who wants to deviate.
So this isn't new.
We've all,
when we've checked equilibrium,
we've always checked that people don't want to deviate.
The only slight difference here is instead of checking that people won't want to
deviate.
I'm checking that types of people won't want to deviate,
but basically the idea is the same that right now it is the same.
So this is not really new.
The new thing,
the new thing is I also need to check,
actually I give myself more on here.
I also need to check,
I need to check that
the employer's beliefs,
the employers beliefs,
ah,
consistent,
consistent with the equilibrium
behavior.
All right,
so let's just stop and pause at that a second.
We'd never written down a condition like this for equilibrium,
but here I have to here there was asymmetric information in the model and in
this equilibrium,
one important party to the equilibrium,
namely the guys who are going to employ you and that's pretty important,
right?
All they really have to do in this model of any importance is form an inference
based on your actions,
right?
They observe whether you get an educational laws and they can include whether or
not you're a good or bad worker,
right?
So we're going to write down as a condition of this being an equilibrium.
Those inferences,
quote makes sense on quote and buy makes sense.
I mean that they're consistent with what actually is happening in equilibrium.
So before we get too nerdy about that,
that's I think why that's a sensible thing to get to,
to require suppose in fact,
suppose the world was like this.
All good workers got Mbas,
all bad workers did not get Mbas and employers thought that the people who got
Mbas were half good and half bad.
All right,
and now that doesn't sound right.
Right?
And see if in fact it's the case that it's the good workers were getting Mbas
and the bad workers who are not,
then the only belief that employers can have that's consistent is the Mbas are
in fact the good workers and the non Mbas are the bad workers.
Is that right?
So I'm not making any deep point here.
I'm just pointing out that we need to make sure that the beliefs that people
hold in this equilibrium are consistent with what's actually going on in the
equilibrium.
Now having said that,
there's no mystery here.
Everything's fine in this particular claim of an equilibrium.
Good workers are the ones who got the Mbas,
bad workers,
the ones who didn't get the Mbas,
and the employers when they see an Mba,
indeed think that good,
and when they see a non Mba,
they indeed think they're bad.
So these beliefs are in fact consistent with behavior.
So we're okay.
Okay,
so I've had to check that.
But it wasn't a big deal I ever care about why I'm checking.
I didn't want people to hold silly beliefs that equilibrium.
That's basically what I'm saying.
All right,
now let's go back and check the check.
The sort of bread and butter thing,
the button.
Final thing is we need to check that no of worker is going to want to deviate in
this equilibrium.
So there's two types of worker.
There's good workers and good workers.
What are they doing in equilibrium?
What are the good workers doing?
An equilibrium.
They're getting an MBA,
right?
For the good workers,
they become Mbas.
And what are the good workers identified as once they've got an Mba,
what does the employer identify them as?
Good workers,
right?
They're identified as good.
They get Mbas that identified as good and that payoff,
the payoff is what?
What's the payoff of the good workers here?
So they get paid,
they get paid 50 which is that productivity,
but it cost them three years of putting up with my homeworks.
So cost them three times five,
right?
Five,
five Phrygia.
So 50 minus three times five is what?
51 street and five is 35 okay,
so this,
they got a total payoff of 35 all right,
let me just pause a second.
I made an assumption here without telling you it's,
I'm going to say it's just to make that,
just to make the math simple,
we'll assume that once you get employed,
you work for a year and then you dropped dead.
All right.
That's a slightly morbid and unpassionate assumption,
but otherwise,
otherwise we have to do kind of present discounted value of your whole future
income and then it turns into an accounting class.
Okay,
so what does assume everybody lives for one year.
Okay.
If you want to do more complicated model,
then that's fine.
The idea will be the site.
All right,
so they get paid 50 it's cost them three times five and they get the total
payoff of 35 all right.
How about if they deviate?
If they deviate,
that means they don't get Mbas,
so they're not Mbas.
They're identified.
What if they don't get Mba?
If they don't get an Mba,
what are they identified as?
What does the employee,
I think the non Mbas are bad.
All right,
so they deviates.
Then the employers think they're bad.
Even if they don't on the table and say they are good,
they're in fact by they identified as bad and so their pay off is water.
What are they going to get paid?
I'm going to get paid 30 I'm sure enough,
35 is bigger than the first seat,
so they're not going to want to deviate.
All right,
so that's good news.
What about the bad workers?
It's check then.
So the bind workers in equilibrium then,
not Mbas,
they don't get an Mba.
They're identified as bad and they're paid wars.
What do they pay to these bad workers?
Somebody the pay
30 right there.
Pay That paid their productivity so that pay off is just thirsty.
They didn't get an education so it was free is they get 30 for free.
So that payoff is just thirsty.
If they deviate,
if the bad workers deviates,
then they get an Mba.
So he comes bad workers,
they find their way into my class and som they have a miserable time.
I have a miserable time cause they're having a miserable time.
But at the end of the day they're identified as good workers.
They didn't tell you this good workers and hence they're paid 50 and they pay
off is 50 minus three times 10 oh one 10 in a penny,
which is approximately 20
is that right?
So they didn't want to deviate either.
I know I've done,
no,
I'm Don.
I've shown it to an equilibrium.
So just to recap,
to show that this was an equilibrium,
I had to show that the good workers happily self select into education and don't
want to deviate and skip business school.
I have to show that the bad workers self select into not getting an education
and don't want to deviate and become a Mbas and I have to show that the
employers in for from this what they should infer from this,
which was fine.
All right,
so I'm done.
This is indeed an equilibrium.
All right?
So notice in this equilibrium the good workers do manage to distinguish
themselves from the bad workers and they do end up getting paid more.
All better.
The cost that they're going to die a year later.
All right,
so this is called a separating equilibrate,
which I can never spell.
I just want to spelling this wrong.
I don't mind.
It's a separating equilibrium.
All right.
Why is it cool to separate in equilibrium?
It's called a separating equilibrium because the types managed to separate and
get identified.
That's slightly misleading.
The good types managed to separating it identified and the bad times they want
to get separated,
but they do get separated.
All right.
Now
how many of you have seen some version of the Spence model before?
Some of you,
right?
All right,
let's go into this in a little bit more detail to see if we've really understood
it.
Okay.
Sorry.
In particular,
actually,
let me get rid of that one
in particular.
Could we get away with a shorter degree here?
We had people going to get Mbas and it took them three years each.
All right.
That seems an awful long time to get an MBA.
So how about,
okay,
how about a one year,
one year MBA?
Right,
and some of you might be a,
I think it's just as homes.
I'm going abstracting his own pole,
but actually this is the kind of thing you hear about all the time.
If you read,
if he doesn't,
the ads and the education press,
you keep on hearing schools,
perhaps schools who lack economics,
professors are putting up the proposals for one year MBA degrees.
All right.
I won't mention any schools by name because I'll probably get in trouble.
All right,
so how about a one year MBA?
Let's see if that will work.
And will allow good workers to separate themselves from bad workers.
Let's assume that the cost per year are the same as they were before.
All right.
And let's suppose that this candidate equilibrium,
this putative equilibrium involves the good workers getting the Mbas,
the bad workers,
not getting an MBA.
And the employers just as before,
identifying Mbas as good and not Mbas as bad question.
Is that an equilibrium?
He doesn't have an equal level.
So who thinks yes?
Who thinks no?
All right.
So you can all tell me why then to the answer is no.
So why is that not an equilibrium?
Why is that not an equilibrium?
Somebody?
Anybody.
What does that all?
Negroes only hasn't answered yet today.
Yeah,
maybe go.
So your,
and your name is what's mine?
I was want to shout out,
shout out Lada the dybbuk adults also benefit from doing the Mba because I'm,
their payoff is still greater.
Good.
So what's wrong in this equilibrium?
It's not the employer's beliefs,
right?
If in fact people did follow this behavior,
then employers would be right to identify Mbas with good.
It's also not the good workers problem.
If in fact employers are going to pay more to Mbas than the good workers,
I could still go even more.
So we're going to want to go ahead and get Mbas.
The problem here,
right?
This is not an equilibrium,
okay?
It's not an equilibrium and the problem is the bad workers,
the bad workers,
incentives are wrong here,
right?
Why?
Because if the bad workers do what they're supposed to do in this equilibrium,
this equilibrium actually this equilibrium,
but in this supposedly equilibrium,
what am I supposed to do is not to get an Mba
and get a pay off of 30 all right?
But if they went to and go to the NBA,
if they deviate,
if they deviate and no one else deviates,
just MTV thing.
If they deviates,
they get an Mba,
okay?
According to the equilibrium that now identified as good workers
identified as and as good.
And so that pay off would be 50 minus one year
at approximately 10 for a total payoff of foresee,
but 40 is higher than thirsty,
so that's violated our equilibrium condition.
I want to see last rites are here.
The bad workers.
If it only took one year of pain and suffering to get an Mba,
the bad workers would go and get an Mba as well.
And that will be trouble because now everyone gets an MBA and it's just like
dancing on the table again.
Alright,
so how long the missed an MBA B in this model with this cost structure,
how many years must it take to get an Mba?
Two years,
right?
Right.
One year it didn't work,
but you can try at home and check that a two year or two year Mba,
a two year MBA will work two years where we just enough to put off the bad
workers.
Leaving aside the numbers though,
what's the idea here?
The idea is that to work as a successful signal,
the signal has to separate the good workers from the bad workers.
That workers have to choose to be separated.
They have to self select into being Mbas or not being Mbas.
And we achieved,
we need just enough pain and suffering and let's be careful,
just enough difference in pain and suffering for the workers to select
correctly.
All right,
so what we need,
what we need,
we need enough
difference difference in cost
for good workers
to get the degree
and for bad workers
not to want to do science.
So one thing we could do is have a two year degree.
How else if you would,
if you would,
apps,
he insisted on having a one year degree.
How could you create a difference in costs that would work?
Suppose you are,
suppose you are employed to advise some university out in the western wear.
Who wants to have a one year degree program?
All right.
What should you do in that one year degree program to make it work?
To make it allow people to separate.
Raising tuition isn't going to work.
Right?
Cause that's the same for good and bad workers need a way to separate the good
and bad workers,
right?
How are you going to do it?
You're gonna make it really hard,
right?
If you want to have a one year degree program,
it's got to be really hard.
You've got to really check out the difference between the good and the bad
workers.
So you need to hire professors who have really bad handwriting.
Alright.
Let's try and take a step back from this model
and see what works.
See what we've learned here.
All right,
let's just try and draw some lessons off this.
Okay.
And I want a chore.
Two kinds of lessons.
I wanted to grow lessons in general about what makes a good,
what makes us successful,
signal in society and may want to draw lessons about education.
So I want to start with nerdy lessons about game theory if you like.
And I want to talk about some more,
more specific lessons about the education system.
Okay.
So the key lesson here is the lesson we just let,
the key lesson is to be a successful signal to be able to separate types of
people.
You need that to be large differences in costs.
All right?
So the first lesson is,
okay,
hey,
good signal
isn't it?
It has to be costly.
It's an,
it has to be differentially costly.
Okay?
Needs to be
differentially
deferentially
costly across types.
And the reason is you want the types to self select so that better be
differences in costs.
Your love at capital here,
you could have differences in benefits,
but we'll leave it as costs on it.
All right?
That's one lesson.
Now what is that telling us in this modal that's telling us that if you make it
very,
very easy to obtain qualifications in the u s society,
for example,
if you lower the standards that you need to get a high school degree and perhaps
you lower the standards to get a college degree.
And I'll say I'm not,
I'm,
I'm not saying that is happening.
I don't want to take a political position on this in England.
That's happening.
I can,
I can do that.
Okay.
They know that seems to be happening,
right?
So you lower the standards it takes to get a high school certificate in England
and then you have to lower the standards to get a college degree.
What are you going to see happen?
You're going to see qualification inflation and you make it easy for everybody
to get the first degree.
The good workers are going to go on and have to get a second degree.
You make it easy to get the second degree,
they're going to go on and get the third degree.
All right?
So what this model predicts is if you,
if you,
if you get rid of this cost difference than workers,
we'll find a new way to raise the cost difference again.
All right?
And the way that takes place and listen in in some economies is you start seeing
qualification inflation.
Okay?
By qualification inflation,
I mean that pretty soon even to drive a dump truck,
you need to have a university degree.
All right.
Okay.
And what are the lessons here for education more generally?
This is a pretty sparse model of education,
but all of you and more and more immediately me are involved in education
system,
so we should care about it a bit.
It's part of the most famous model of education.
As I say at one,
somebody that,
oh,
we'll prize.
What is it telling us about education?
So the first thing I claim,
I claim that this is a rather pessimistic model of education.
Why is this a pessimistic model of education?
What's pessimistic about this model?
Let's talk about that a bit.
Anybody?
Some some hands up.
Don't we give them different hands was why is this a pessimistic model of
education?
Way,
way over that.
Got To get your head in another part of the room.
It'll,
he'll give the camera on a work out anyway.
All right.
You don't learn in high school.
Definitely.
No good,
good.
Let's just start the chat.
They end of the microphone,
but that was right.
You don't learn anything at school in this model,
right?
Right.
This is a model with no learning.
There's no learning in this model.
All right?
In finance.
People in this model go in with that.
Productivity is at 50 and 30 I may come out with that.
Productivity is at 1530 nothing you do at school in riches you or makes you more
productive.
That's a pretty pessimistic lesson.
Here we are in lecture number.
What does that section,
I'm 23 or something.
Right on the message of this,
of this model is you guys haven't learned anything.
You've just had a lot of pain and suffering.
All right.
All right,
so there's no learning in this model.
There's no learning.
Okay.
Hi.
No,
I hope,
I hope that's not true as a model of education,
right?
I hope it's not true that we only have pain,
but never,
never lived by us.
Let's pretend it's true,
at least for now and see where it takes us.
All right,
so a second observation of this model.
If we believe this model of education in which you don't learn a thing,
education is just being used by those people who are good anyway,
to separate from those people who were bad anyway.
Right?
Then education in this model is socially wasteful.
Why is education socially wasteful of this model?
And what sense is it socially wasteful
thinking from the point of view and economist in this model,
the productivity of the workers doesn't change because of education,
but some resources were used,
right?
Some resources were used by the good workers to get an education,
At the end of the day,
the good workers are better off,
the bad workers are worse off,
all right?
But that's,
and uh,
employers were the same as they would have been otherwise.
All right.
But that's just redistribution,
right?
There's no product from education.
Right?
But resources,
resources were wasted in education and I that makes sense.
So in particular,
in our two year equilibrium,
right?
In free air equilibrium,
it was the good workers who went to college or no,
in this case went to business school and they wasted three years at five apiece,
right?
Until there's a waste of 15 a waste of 10 and the two year model.
All right?
According to this model,
education is socially wasteful.
How do we actually visualize that waste and society's expectation,
the model seriously,
where is that waste manifested in society?
Okay.
Where's that waste manifested?
Yeah.
So you guys aren't working and where else does it matter who you guys sitting
here as part of the waste?
You should be out doing something else and where else is the waste?
Me?
Right,
right,
right.
You should take her to a port.
Yale,
Yale professors.
Stop using them as Yale professors and wasting those resources and have us go
out and till the fields.
All right.
Drive taxis or something.
All right,
so there's a social waste here,
right?
And that what we should do is,
according to this model,
is we should send the professors
to drive taxes or dump trucks.
I guess
I'm not claiming would be good at driving dump trucks.
Our comparative advantages,
certainly in teaching classes rather than drunk driving dump trucks,
but it turns out in this model,
teaching classes is completely waste of time.
All right?
And therefore you're better off using those resources to drive dump trucks.
All right,
third nosiest that in this model,
the results of education is what?
It's good for the good workers.
You guys managed to separate yourselves and get paid high wages.
That's nice for the Yale graduates here,
but who are the losers in this model?
Who are the losers?
The bad workers,
the 90% of workers in this economy who aren't naturally gifted,
who aren't going to find indication easy.
They in this model,
end up being paid 30 without the education system.
How much would they have been paid?
32 all right.
So this model increases inequality,
and in this model,
education increases in the quality and it doesn't increase inequality in a
benign way.
Just by making the rich red shot,
it increases in the quality by making the poor poorer.
Alright?
Increase education in this model increases
inequality in this model.
It actually hurts.
It hurts
the pole.
Yeah.
How about strikes me as a pretty important lesson,
actually.
Again,
I don't think we should take this model to literally in the real world.
I at least hope that some of you are learning something at Yale.
You're looking at me extremely doubtful.
If you could possibly let again.
Yeah,
so maybe you're not,
I dunno,
right?
But in the real world,
I'd like to believe people are letting him.
Yeah,
but one of the things that's going on in education,
in addition to learning,
one of the things is that you guys are separating ourselves.
I'm signaling to employers that you're going to be,
that you're going to work out,
you're going to be good workers for them.
As a consequence,
that's great for you,
but someone else is being paid less.
This is infringement is an important lesson in,
in a to here in an election year,
in every election year in America,
I've been in a few action years in America.
Now.
There are two things that all politicians agree on,
whether that far right or far left or politicians agree on two things.
I agree.
The two things are good.
One kissing babies too.
They all want to be quote the education president.
Is that right?
All of them is that right now as a parent of some babies,
I'm not sure I want to have politicians kissing babies,
but that's not,
that's not,
that's for another day.
All right.
The point here is what we're learning,
they don't go yet.
Guys,
what we're learning here is that if education hurts the poor,
maybe we shouldn't be so keen to decide that we should subsidize the education
sector itself,
although as an indicator,
I hope he don't tell me what the,
tell that to anybody.
All right.
What's the takeaway message of this model and the takeaway messages for
education to work as a signaling device to education,
to generate a separating equilibrium.
Some children have to be left behind.
All right.
We'll talk about that.
Moral Wednesday.